and our shout out tonight for a reporter
in Memphis who with the helper Pro
Publica
set up a small nonprofit journalism
operation and then took on that city's
biggest health care provider in a series
of stories that as you will see had a
very surprising outcome
it's the largest healthcare provider in
Memphis and in a promotional video
celebrating its 100-year anniversary
Methodist Bonior hospital makes much of
what it calls a culture of compassion
true to our faith-based mission and
Methodist heritage we have a tradition
of building up our entire community
through a host of local programs from
free cancer screenings to childhood
asthma reduction we are committed to
improving all lives regardless of their
means but a year-long investigation by
journalist Wendy Thomas called the
hospital's compassion into question I
would go to court every Wednesday for
five months watching Methodist in action
documenting an aggressive debt
collection system by the hospital
against those who could not afford to
pay their bills so over a five-year
period Methodist Hospital filed more
than 83 hundred lawsuits and when they
won a judgment as they always did they
were more successful in their attempts
to garnish wages compared to the city's
other large hospitals and the people
they were filing the lawsuits against so
a lot of those people were very
low-income the benches would be full of
defendants who were really ill-equipped
to deal with this really savvy legal
team that also had you know good rapport
with the judges for Thomas it was just
the latest installment in a series of
reports about her hometown for a website
she founded called MLK 50 standing for
50 years since Martin Luther King was
assassinated in Memphis this story began
kind of with a broader question which is
know why is Memphis so poor it's the
second poorest large city in the nation
come and we wanted to think about the
money that is siphoned out from these
households and so that got us on the
track of debt and specifically medical
debt
and the court records told the story of
how Methodists relentlessly went after
those who could not pay often huge
medical bills
anybody can get sick right any all of us
can relate to that and these people's
mistake if they did make a mistake was
being poor and sick at the same time but
the hospital at first tried to ignore
Thomas and her small nonprofit outlet so
the hospital refused multiple requests
to be interviewed
we of course you know operating by the
no surprises policy you know let them
know what our findings were you know
presented lists of questions and they
typically didn't answer most of the
questions and just pretty much Stonewall
us during the whole investigation NIDA
scathing report exposes how a non-profit
Hospital in Memphis is suing the poor in
this city over and over again but when
her story went public it was the talk of
Memphis Methodist filed more than eighty
three hundred lawsuits for unpaid
hospital bills during the past five
years so shame as it turns out is a
powerful motivator and after the stories
broke I'm including one about the
hospital suing its own employees who
made sometimes as little as twelve
dollars an hour
I'm outrage was immediate widespread
within five days of the initial story
the hospital suspended all court
collection activities and within another
30 days they announced major reforms to
the charity care policies making them
twice as generous as they had be had
been but the biggest surprise was yet to
come one by one the people who were
being sued by Methodists discovered that
their debt had been wiped out
[Applause]
in total they ended up erasing at least
eleven point nine million dollars in
unpaid hospital debt that more than
fifty three hundred defendants had so
this is this is good news for for a poor
community like Memphis so for those
fifty three hundred what actually
happened their balance has been marked
as zero with the courts zero it's yeah
it's gone and that must have made you
feel pretty good yeah it did it did I
can remember sitting in the car with the
hospital housekeeper who had been sued
she owed twenty three thousand dollars
that was more than she made the prior
year and I showed her her case satisfied
notice where show said that her balance
was the euro and she she was a static
yeah I'll remember that long live the
story has brought much-needed attention
to her MLK fifty project which has been
funded in part by the nonprofit group
ProPublica in their efforts to promote
good local investigative journalism I
think for journalists particular who are
in low income low wealth communities
like Memphis to think about poverty not
just in terms of who suffers from it but
who profits from it and and look for
those who profit and what's a nod to
what systems can be changed so you're
gonna keep going yeah absolutely for as
long as long as we can who's next on
your hit list I can't tell you that
indeed good work Wendy Thomas that's our
program for tonight thanks for joining
us we'll see you back here next week